une promotion 100% féminine le château
de versailles comme promis lieu de
rendez vous la nouvelle saison de la job
academy a été lancée lundi 14 novembre
une initiative portée par la fondation
agir contre l'exclusion des yvelines sur
le modèle du parrainage une dizaine de
demandeurs d'emploi sont ainsi suivis
par des employés du château de
versailles pendant quatre mois le
premier rendez vous était l'occasion
pour les différents binôme de se
découvrir et d'apprendre à se connaître
cette première prise de contact est très
drôle 1 puisque personne se connaît donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui séduit
énormément ça met à l'aise tout le monde
est là c'est une première un premier
contact voir si ça ce match a tout
simplement et si ça ce match et ben on
fixe le deuxième rendez-vous il s'est
lancé et ça ce match justement entre
amandine et alexandra fille les
marraines vont se donner rendez-vous
toutes les deux semaines avec pour
ambition de permettre à alexandra de
retrouver un emploi le plus rapidement
possible ensemble en fait on va on va
faire en sorte que je trouve ma voix on
va se fixer des objectifs à chaque
rendez vous est donc comme ce sera ce
sera plus carré pour moi et du coup ce
sera plus facile d'aller de l'avant elle
a déjà un parcours
e pour moi déjà cadre elle a déjà des
idées quoi qu'elle en dise voilà donc je
pense que ça va être facile de
l'orienter au maximum et puis elle a
comme un rapport au public qui est
proche de ce que je fais donc du coup ça
va être ma s'il essayait d'orienter au
mieux pour cette deuxième saison de la
job academy le club face est associée
une nouvelle fois au château de
versailles en plus des rencontres
bimensuelles plusieurs ateliers
collectifs seront également organisés
est dix binômes participent à cette
nouvelle édition soit deux de plus que
l'an passé